And there are two correct answers here and that is the second answer and the fourth answer.
And the reason for that is as follows.
If you managed to have a polynomial time reduction from a problem X to a problem Y,
that means that you can take any input to the problem X and then use Y to solve it.
What it does not mean is that you can take very input for Y and use X to solve it.
The reduction is only one way.
But that means if you managed to reduce the problem X to a problem Y,
then solving Y must require at least as much effort or power as solving X.
So that means that Y is at least as hard to solve as X and not the other way around as I just said.
Now on the other hand, since Y is at least as hard to solve as X that means
if you find a way to solve Y in polynomial time then of course you can also solve X in polynomial time
because this reduction here takes polynomial time and then solving that problem
would also take polynomial time.
On the other hand, if you can solve X in polynomial time, so this problem here,
that doesn't really mean anything for Y because as we just said Y is at least as hard to solve as X
but it doesn't have the same hardness or is easier in any way.
This implication here does not hold true and those two are the only ones that are true.
Now if this quiz confused you a little bit, I find a good way to memorize this
what the reduction from the X to Y means is that if you have a reduction from X to Y
that basically means that this problem X here must be able to fit into the problem Y
and that is why this problem Y here is in a way larger or harder to solve than X
so you take this problem X and put it into Y that is what the polynomial time reduction
can be pictured as and at least from me that's very helpful.
And of course I do hope that it is for you as well.